were you really blazing it uh like
taking bong loads in Silicon Valley
sometimes I kind of you know I left that
show after four
seasons in part because no one is ever
like my favorite uh season of Breaking
Bad season seven
yeah now when after a show goes four or
five seasons
it doesn't get better that's why they
say jump the shark you know so we got to
that point also I was kind of on
autopilot it wasn't interesting to me
and I knew the characters so well and
we'd done so much with that it was so
[ __ ] it was so funny I I was I'd
gotten to a point where I was kind of
yeah I could totally go in and do I
would always get high when I was done
with my coverage I would just smoke and
I feel like your character would like
take actual like bong loads on the show
were you so that is a Hollywood weed but
you never did really I threw a little in
there
you know what I mean and uh and so but I
would um I feel like nobody else in the
[ __ ] world could have played that
role dude like you you were so goddamn
genius in that thank you man yeah it was
I mean that's all my judge I just talked
to Jimmy oh yeah a couple days ago we
live in the same city and I always like
pass them on the street but I never say
what's up really you got to see what's
up I mean nice guy like it's a such a
fan of you on that show thank you man
yeah I mean I'm about to maybe do this
Christmas movie where I think no one
else can play Santa in the way Santa
I love it yeah it's gonna be great but
yeah it's you know I I would smoke a
little bit but I said I gotta I have to
take her off and do something else it's
the same reason like after Deadpool 2 I
was like I can't do this character again
if he had his own movie or something but
I've sort of done this character and
then people be like okay I can't believe
you're not gonna do Deadpool 3 wedge and
I always say
um have you seen hangover three
and like oh yeah and I'm like didn't it
kind of taint hangover one and there was
like yeah yeah so I also think being in
the third
sequel of anything you know being a
third installment of a franchise it's a
problem you know only in Marvel has it
they've been able to sort it out that
got pretty bad too Police Academy got
pretty bad Jaws got pretty bad The
Godfather Three wasn't a great yeah
because it always feels like a cash grab
because that's what it is yeah you know
the story has been told the story that
could have been out first told maybe you
do a prequel and that's interesting but
the third horror movie some I mean you
know [ __ ] you just reminded me that
we've got a new house of the Dragon
what's that that prequel to Game of
Thrones Sunday nights right see I can't
Kate I Love Game of Thrones until the
dragons
we just were like we're not dungeons
drug we like the power struggle yeah
whatever but then when fake dragons come
in we kind of lost interest but you love
it I mean like I did when the dragons
are flying across the screen yeah it's a
little bit whack but it is so fun though
it doesn't ruin the whole thing for me
yeah it is so so fun I love that you
loved Silicon Valley both of you oh my
God so we were on tour together and it
was just like [ __ ] it couldn't get it
yeah it's a it was a fun show yeah it's
really really good I think that clip was
awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what I've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions my first books Five star rated
on Amazon and I have no doubt this one
will be too so get the autograph copy
right now at stevo.com
yeah dude